[Musique]
on peut rang
enfin
le vieillissement de la population qu'on
a dans leur est cher et celui qu'on
risque d'avoir dans 20 ans ou 40 ans au
niveau métropole
on va probablement être pilote sur des
façons d'anticiper la médecine de demain
la majorité des personnes veulent rester
jusqu'à leur fin ce jour a2micile et
puis en ehpad
il y à un reste à charge qui est assez
élevé et que beaucoup ne peuvent pas
financer
on sait effectivement qu'on n'aura pas
plus de places d'ehpad dont cinq en
disant qu'il y en a aujourd'hui et donc
nous notre souhait c'est faire en sorte
que les gens ne tombent pas trop vite
dans la dépendance dans le loir et cher
un habitant sur 10 à plus de 75 soit
près de 48 personnes la majorité des
retraités à un point commun la volonté
de vivre autonome le plus longtemps
possible à la maison c'est merveilleux
elle pouvoir rester chez soi jusqu'au
bout
les gens qui ont qui restent à domicile
sont souvent beaucoup plus heureux que
ce qu'on voit en maison de retraite ans
a serré c'est bien évident veut éviter
la maison de retraite si c'est se
retrouver avec les gens qui ont les
mêmes problèmes que vous éventuellement
plus grave alors c'est pas la peine de
de s'agréger à cette population je
préfère rester contrat avec des jeunes
la maison de retraite inquiète
d'ailleurs seuls 8% des personnes âgées
vivent dans une structure comme un ehpad
odette et joseph viennent de fêter leurs
soixante six ans de mariage elle est une
et donc familiales sont vraiment en
avoir conscience
elle s'occupe de son mari de 93 ans qui
n'entend plus très bien qui ne parle
plus vraiment on est là on y restera là
jusque tant que dieu nous rappelle oui
le pire c'est le soir parce que bien
souvent il y perd un peu la tête à celui
des poussins petitjean pousse un peu des
jambes je ne vais pas qu'il soit trop à
gauche et j'ai peur qu'ils tombent un
poussin petit en binômes --à énorme une
médiocre les 2000 avait pas on n'est pas
tous vos bacs non non pas toujours mon
temps or on y avait quand même pas est
ce que vous voulez le fermer le gilet ou
pas si ce couple peut rester dans sa
maison
c'est grâce au réseau de professionnels
une aide soignante pour lui tous les
matins une aide à domicile pour elle les
orteils ça va mieux
claire babeau ne vient que six heures
par semaine chez odette et joseph mais
elle fait un peu partie de la famille
elle fait tous se connaître ne peut plus
faire la soulage pour les tâches
ménagères les plus difficiles mais pas
seulement un petit bisou pour moi je ne
voudrais pas comme l'argon goudé ah ben
je vous donne plus madame madame gbagbo
a défini annonce la fin d'ailleurs je
crois que je me fasse rien su
je me fasse l on me retirais cette dame
ah oui oui oui oui je me ferai
en fait c'est une dame impeccable aller
comme ça j'ai choisi ça parce que je
voulais avoir plus de contacts avec les
personnes avoir un échange et
et les aider c'est ça qui me
qui me convenait
[Musique]
direction vendôme pour la journée des
aidants pour la première fois la santé
de ceux qui aident leurs proches à
rester chez eux étaient au coeur des
débats
ce stade de demander aux autres on est
trop fier la journée des aidants
aujourd'hui c'est un moyen de commencer
à sensibiliser parce que
oui moi je suis dedans je ne savais pas
ah ben oui je suis au quotidien à côté
de mon parent qui ne fait pas tout mon
conjoint
le fait d'être repérés comme aidant nous
aide nous professionnels à tendre la
main vers ces aidants pour pas qu'ils
s'épuisent constate non que l'aidant
principal entouré des siens souvent
passent deux trois quatre fois plus de
temps que les aidants professionnels
mais si on le décharge des tâches
compliqué qui nécessite une compétence
particulière mais psychologiquement et
physiquement il tiendra plus longtemps
c'est tout l'enjeu trouver et coordonner
les petites mains professionnelles
essentielles au maintien à domicile
aides ménagères aide soignante porteurs
de repas ces femmes pour la plupart
sillonne les routes du département en
courant après la montre à l'essai oui
nathalie vient prodiguer des soins
d'hygiène et de confort tous les matins
à cette dame de 97 ans elle ne voit plus
mais elle tient à son apparence est à sa
13 parfait dans la vie si vous tenez pas
bien c'est pas parce que vous êtes tout
ce que vous devez moi j'ai des
petits-enfants ils ont 11 ans 15 16 ans
et 20 ans il me regarde ni me voir si
particulier heureusement que je vous ai
tous les jours comment se ferait et puis
vous vous tenez compagnie fois ça nous
permet à nous en tant que soignant
d'avoir une surveillance ans au
quotidien de la de madame brillant sinon
elle pourrait elle saurait en structure
si on n'intervenait pas chaque jour
comme la moyenne des seniors du loir et
cher
madame brillant touche une retraite de
1200 euros en plus de l'aide soignante
prise en charge par la sécurité sociale
elle bénéficie d'une aide ménagère tous
les après-midi et vu sa perte
d'autonomie
elle a bien sûr penser à la maison de
retraite je ne peux pas me payer une
maison médicale on remet centre-presse
la bonne solution c'est de rester chez
moi quand je peux parce que le
souhaitent dans une maison trop mais ça
coûte très cher mais je n'ai pas les
moyens
il
bonjour madame voir jouer
vous allez bien oui pour bien vieillir à
domicile le portage de repas est un
maillon essentiel
la santé passe aussi par une
alimentation équilibrée mais c'est bien
vous avez tous mangé mais dès qu'il ya
une barquette qui est suspecte ou
périmés elle va directement à la
poubelle
il vaut mieux leur proposer le lendemain
leur ramener un potage c'est un potage
ou une petite entrée ou un dessert
plutôt de qu'elle soit malade et
puisqu'il faut être très vigilant fait
l'état josiane se fait livrer trois
repas a réchauffé par semaine car elle
ne peut plus rester debout longtemps et
ses bras se fatigue vite elles dépensent
120 euros par mois pour ce service
souvent d'être trop alors je roule en
partageant aux deux et puis je mange
tout le temps eu d'entrée à dessert
alors semblé se fit dans le centre
brandon bien
pour aider les personnes âgées à rester
à domicile les pouvoirs publics allège
les factures c'est le département qui
est en charge des solidarités
à ce titre il verse l'allocation
personnalisée d'autonomie apa
pour en bénéficier il faut avoir plus de
60 ans tout d'abord le médecin traitant
délivre un certificat médical de perte
d'autonomie
ensuite il l'envoie au conseil
départemental là un travailleur social
se rend au domicile du demandeur
il évalue ses besoins et lui attribue un
nombre d'heures de services à la
personne dans le loir et cher
dix mille personnes bénéficient de l'apa
la papesse déjà très lourd puisque c'est
c'est plus de 40 millions pour le
département mais surtout l'état ne nous
est plus hauteur que de 50% sur ce
budget là donc on doit mettre plus de 20
millions chaque année et ceux se ses
modalités sont à peu près les mêmes dans
tous les départements
on sait qu'en gros il ya un euro sur
deux qui est donnée aujourd'hui par
l'état et seulement un héros sur deux en
dix ans le budget du département a
presque doublé
la solution est donc d'aider les
personnes âgées à rester autonome le
plus longtemps possible notamment en
proposant une adaptation des domiciles
c'est le but de la maison bleue un lieu
unique en france maison des années 50
comme on trouve beaucoup dans le
loir-et-cher avec la première difficulté
chez soi souvent c'est de franchir la
surélévation donc non mon différentes
solutions poids pour un même besoin au
présente différentes solutions des
solutions adaptées à chaque budget du
jardin à la chambre en passant par la
salle de bain toutes les pièces sont
présentées
pas question ici d'enjeux financiers
l'idée est de proposer des aménagements
ou des outils qui facilitent la vue
grâce aux boutons si tu as besoin
d'attraper quelque chose tu peux tu peux
faire varier la hauteur du mobilier la
maison bleue donc elle est là pour
présenter
une multiplicité de possibilités
d'adaptation que ce soit en termes de
prévention ou en termes de compensations
de déficiences et toutes sortes de
déficiences tout public confondu les
professionnels comme les particuliers
mais peuvent venir avec des personnes
concernées pour manipuler se mettre
directement au situation et voir ce qui
leur convient le mieux le maintien à
domicile en toute sécurité sera donc
facilitée par l'innovation technique la
domotique est la spécialité de dôme
album en quatre ans ces techniciens qui
dépendent de la fondation partage et vie
ont équipé 1300 foyers du loir et cher
vous avez bien je vois bien pour les
bénéficiaires de l'apa l'abonnement
mensuel revient à 15 euros par mois pour
prévenir les chutes
l'installation principal est un chant
lumineux avec détecteur de présence à la
lever du lit on peut être un petit peu
désorienté là ça va permettre justement
de baliser le chemin sans pour autant
empêcher les personnes de garder leurs
habitudes et d'allumer leur propre
lumière l'abonnement comprend aussi
l'entretien des installations ainsi
qu'un bracelet de sécurité reliés aux
boîtiers de téléassistance en cas de
chute
j'aimerais que jamais je dois mais si
j'appuie très sonné et puis d'abord elle
me parle par là et puis après rennes le
téléphone pour parler
environ une fois par mois elle m'appelle
pour savoir comment jouer plus qu'une
assistance technique
beaucoup de personnes attendent ces
visites et ses appels pour rompre la
solitude et l'ennui pour bien vieillir
l'entourage est essentiel quand les
enfants sont loin
une alternative existe la famille
d'accueil
[Musique]
j'ai pu s'offusquer si vous êtes un vrai
il a ainsi nommé béatrice a décidé de
devenir accueillant familial
à 46 ans elle est agréée par le conseil
départemental pour héberger trois
personnes un choix de métier qui lui est
apparu comme une évidence un contact une
aider les gens je sais dans un
laboratoire pharmaceutique est pas mal
aussi mais ça c'est mieux
jeannine est hébergé par patricia pour
1200 euros par mois elle a essayé de
vivre seul après la mort de son mari
mais sa famille s'inquiétait et pour
elle la question d'aller en maison de
retraite ni d'aller chez ces enfants
mais je trouve anormal quand ce couple à
la vie de nos enfants les élevé pour
être heureux et non pas pour s'occuper
d'eux quand on est
j'ai le plaisir de les voir très souvent
mais on va pas je vais peut-être
recherche pour eux on fait tout ce qu'on
peut pour les élever leur donner du
bonheur
le défi du maintien à domicile des
personnes âgées restent de taille la
possibilité de bien vieillir chez soi
dépendra surtout dans nombre suffisant
de médecins de personnel soignant et
dead à domicile des métiers qui peine à
recruter et pourtant
pour que nos aînés vivent tout aux
normes jusqu au bout c'est toute la
société qui va devoir les accompagner
[Musique]